[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to the
Powerpuff Girls
well I can't say I grew up with the show
I think I was entering college at the
time I can say I'm quite familiar with
it because well it was everywhere my
first introduction to it was a Space
Coast cartoon showing pilots for there's
a new channel Cartoon Network well it
looked a little different that does now
it was still unlike anything I've ever
seen it was like a mix between Ren and
Stimpy and anime it was uniquely bizarre
and adequately funny
the popularity grew so much that Warner
Brothers eventually gave them their own
Powerpuff Girl movie the Powerpuff Girl
movie being the first theatrical release
from Cartoon Network this superhero
beat'em up got an astounding okay
response from critics and received an
amazingly adequate box office and the
response from viewers was a phenomenal
school nobody really talks about this
movie too much and on some level I can
see why kind of just shows up does this
job and then leaves your consciousness
kind of like fish but is there more to
analyze about this movie is there
something to recognize beyond just
distracting you for an hour and a half
let's hope not or else the Madea movies
will have nothing to survive on so slap
on your white socks and act like having
no fingers or toes is part of being a
kindergartner I'm glad somebody else
have that childhood this is the
Powerpuff Girls movie ah back when
Warner Brothers the pan and scan would
be the future I miss you I soars in the
city of Townsville crime is on the rise
as well as narrators talking about how
crime is on the rise for there is a man
who looks back to a sweeter time
everything was nice when women's eyes
weren't black and white cookies the
world has changed this man the narrator
simply calls the professor tell me
there's a fan theory connecting these
two goes home to conduct an experiment
while his lab monkey starts wreaking
havoc
hey hey it's how some fans react to the
new Powerpuff Girls cartoon with a weird
name like that he won't go anywhere
the monkey spills chemical X into the
mix and well using the opening don't
look at them too long I think the ring
video is in their eyes
yeah like many of us say their look can
be a little night terror ask but they're
cute personalities do shine through the
more he interacts with them I can't
believe it
I wanted to make some kids that liked it
each good and bad right and wrong and in
turn maybe they do some good for this
terrible town and now I can it's nice
knowing the motivation after he did the
motivational thing he quickly finds out
that they have superpowers thank God for
this slow pan over to Chemical X or else
we never would have found out what did
it except for the other times you
focused on it and the fact that's
repeated over and over and the show's
opening credits I think kids can connect
the dots what the stupid was affected to
and abandons them for the time being the
girls help the professor do everyday
things like paint their room bring in
toys and even put in some windows I
could see some windows I'll call a
contractor tomorrow it didn't know Satan
sonam at everything nice you will also
see does Cookie Crisp before bedtime the
dog is cute it looks like they're laser
eyes make the windows and all this
oddness tires them out so they're put to
bed while the professor comes across a
picture they drew
okay the peachy promised me non-stop
frenetic animated action which sounds
more like a critic quote than a warning
but you come through what my parental
guidance is required the next day he
takes them to school and they're
introduced to their teacher miski why
does every kid's eyes look like buffalo
bill should be staring down them do you
think they'll be okay because they're
really special I mean really special
don't worry we take all kinds of kids
but that one the corner for example
hasn't blinked in days it still haunts
my soul the kids seem to fit in fine
until they play a game of tag what's
going on here
wait puppets testicles dropped at an
early age the kids show the girls how to
play and they take it well a little too
seriously
Popples recovers and the girls use their
superpowers to play the game destroying
chunks of the neighborhood well the
video games designed what other
merchandise do we have to make so okay
well this is a cute idea it goes a
little long like a lot a little long the
whole tag sequence from beginning to end
is nine minutes nine minutes it's like
imagining one of those pointless fight
scenes in the Matrix Reloaded except to
make it even more pointless they're just
playing tag
you're Garrett you're here and you're it
you're it gara gara gara well to point
toward Yuri Jada granted the action is
kind of creative but there's no conflict
outside that people just want them to
stop playing tag that's a superhero
movie even for kids that's not
especially exciting this makes me laugh
though you know I've got a nice guy I'll
just assume by that like I'm screaming
both people are dead
[Music]
the fine thing is man a steel fan
somehow interpret this as saving the
city the mayor of Townsville sees the
destruction and in an almost minute and
a half filled up to a joke I like to
play the long game in this he gets a
pickle instead of responding to the
violence back when a politician doing
that almost sounded silly
[Music]
that classic mayor slowly putting pickle
closer to his mouth while sweet girls
destroying the city quickly rushed
towards you I don't care how long you
take to film it the routine is timeless
the girls eventually crashed into him
and the professor runs into the girls
finally taking them home three little
girls had a very busy day today well I'm
glad you had so much fun because
tomorrow will be a busy day too we're
going to explain to truthers why what
you did wasn't planned by the government
it's your super powers I don't think you
should use them in public anymore just
give Townsville a little time to
understand your specialness we're gonna
try and eat frozen to this but the
earworm we have is a literal earworm
people often get scared or angry when
they don't understand something special
or unique that's silly
well I think so too oh and you blue
up kind of a legit reason to get mad the
news spreads through town and the next
day the kids are not greeted with much
warmth well that PG rating did not
include Yosemite Sam language the
professor is brought in for questioning
leaving the girls alone after school
maybe he hates us and here I thought ed
Helmes was the worst thing to happen to
tag has more news spreads about them
shocking even mini ron jeremy the girls
feel like outcasts
don't worry the invention of social
media will balance everything out there
is something I like about them not using
their powers to go home realizing what
it's like to be a normal person living
through their destruction things get
even more intense when they're stopped
by a local gang you know just because
the guy new member doesn't mean the
guerillas need to do crossovers but
they're saved by you know and they
follow him to a box he lives it have
been lashed by heart that's disgusting
because you are he says his name is Jojo
and like them he's an outcast heads up
this is my favorite shot in the movie
and if you just give people time they'll
start to understand your specialness
yeah you just gotta believe in yourself
mmm that's entailing a bottom Carter as
a monkey look so creepy so funny enough
the movie goes from a snail's pace to
suddenly pretty damn fast when Jojo
reveals his ideas and how the girls can
help John then take this device I built
into the volcano losing my ideas are
your powers we will build to help the
town to make it a better place machine
Jesus the micro machine guy took over
his editor they agreed to help Jojo with
his plan to repair the town even though
they don't understand what the machine
they're making does as a reward he takes
him to the zoo but he seems to have
other plans than just sightsee it's
funny because butts always wanted to go
to commercial on that line
[Applause]
[Music]
hi guys I'm chaplain Doug's new kitty
have you heard about this Mouse on a
string god I love this Mouse on a string
until I get bored by it a little bored
by the mouse on the street now I'm back
to it Mouse's on strings are great and
did you know that you can see Doug and
the rest of the gang at Grand Rapids
comic-con
it's November 9th to the 11th it'll be
my owner Doug what a great guy
his brother Rob what a great guy Malcolm
ray great guy Tamra chambers great guy
and Jim Jay Roth coincidentally also a
great guy there's a lot of other great
guests there so we hope you check them
out me I'm gonna go ruin Doug's couch
what a great couch oh that wasn't
supposed to happen
isn't that great I'm just gonna snip
this for a while
I love sniffing this for a while up that
one fell too if I'm just gonna keep
sniffing this one for a while I'm a
really weird cat so go to this site to
figure out how you can get tickets to
Grand Rapids Comic Con in Michigan and
smelt scratching posts on couches you
don't know what you're missing this is
great
[Applause]
so after putting darts and all the
monkeys at the zoo bubbles notices a
baby dropped his toy
I thought the zoo kept all the animals
in cages damn bitch
I'll have any other jokes it's just damn
bitch Stephan yourselves do their
heartless words and now it's time to
play dude that's totally got another
meaning they are unaware that your
actions will have helped change their
world forever
dude that's totally got another meaning
surprised oh yeah dude that's totally
got another meaning still be mad at us
for playing tag no dude that's totally
got another meaning yes
okay well that's more just not telling
the truth I am gonna play that with this
clip would I lie to you
[Music]
the cops drop the professor back home as
Jojo starts his evil plan transporting
all the monkeys from the zoo to his lair
[Music]
Green nothing good in the lair is
evergreen
[Music]
thank you again for that movie do you
want to talk about something
their brains all seem to grow as the
next morning both the kids and children
will prepare for their big day
the girls things are gonna help the town
but they accidentally caused the
apocalypse oops
Jojo think it's the best introduction to
a new name since the artist formerly
known as Prince
the hobo formerly known as Jojo is no
more from this day forward I shall be
known as that's so funny I totally
glanced over that there's two weird
focuses on butts in that shot again
movie you want to talk about something I
don't know who to believe I thought you
were good
e to profess a but Mojo Jojo finds out
his minions want to be in charge instead
of his my name is and here is my speed I
don't remember getting high but I'm
clearly high I think it was brave to
have the makers of Dexter's Lab do the
pink elephant scene in Tim Burton's
Dumbo sprite can be better than what
we've really yet meanwhile on Planet
artsy cut away your Powerpuff Girls that
tree of life the girls seem to sit on a
I'll just say it I have no idea what
maybe it's the debris of the town
flowing into space maybe it's where
Marvin the Martian lives maybe it's all
the sets to the Superman sequels that
are never gonna make but whatever it is
they try to figure out what to do
what is this a Swedish expressionist
belches punch yet but they hear the
professor cry in pain despite he's kind
of the reason they were up there to
begin with
and they rushed back to Salem on the way
they find they can save other people too
that's my cat's favorite scene you
should see the look on his face that's
the face he makes but Buttercup punch is
one of them and they get an idea that's
what'll save the day we had to do so
many PSAs to balance this out wait
that's not a thing when this was made
oh good just blow up to blow
up I'll just say it it's really weird
but really awesome to see this much
animated violence in a kid's film again
I don't think I've seen this much
hand-drawn explosion punching for
children since GI Joe the movie
but gotta say the professor from Mojo
Jojo but he turns himself into a giant
because Giants are cool well somebody's
found a new beer label the girls of
course trying to stop him leading to
even more fun action ones who hated you
the ones who are clearly artists and
writers trying to get their faces in the
picture I haven't looked it up or
anything but look at them that's clearly
drawn by people eleven sense of humor
about how they look well that's a shock
I really thought they were gonna join if
do you think these are Mission
Impossible twist they defeat him just as
the professor comes up with an antidote
to shrink him down the girls even have a
chance to take away their powers but the
town wants them to keep thank you oh my
god you can talk so the town loves them
now and lets them fight evil wherever it
works Powerpuff Girls hey that's a good
name for them I like that
I wonder if they will I wanna try it I
mean I was gonna go with creepy sperm
dolls but I guess that works too
the Powerpuff Girls movie has a strange
problem of taking itself too seriously
which is fine if you want to try
something new but it needed a more
complex story with twists and emotions
when the action the comedy does get
going though
it is kind of fun it's not as fast or
creative as the show but the up to
production value does make it nicer to
look at especially for a time period
when this kind of style just wasn't seen
in movies nowadays this kind of
simplistic style with fast action is all
over the place but back then this was
pretty rare so I guess you could argue
on a technical level it was a little
ahead of its time as a movie though
that's all right I would have liked if
it was a bit more clever in its writing
but it still felt big enough to be more
than just an extended episode fly on in
and check it out for yourself
I mean it's got to be better than next
week's movie what are your thoughts on
that Chaplin I think that face says it
all
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing the
Gary Sinise foundation they serve our
nation by honoring our defenders
veterans first responders their families
and those in need they do this by
creating and supporting unique programs
designed to entertain educate inspire
strengthen and build communities the
experiences of War leave an indelible
impact on our defenders when they return
to civilian life the physical emotional
and psychological challenges they face
are often difficult as citizens we
benefit from the freedom and security
they fight to protect so supporting our
heroes is a responsibility we all should
share each of the foundation programs
originated from Gary Sinise's personal
relationships with our nation's service
community and a wide range of nonprofits
he has supported for decades with the
creation of this foundation his crusade
now supports all those who sacrifice on
our behalf
active-duty veterans first responders
and their loved ones if you look at
their site on their youtube channel you
can see all the brave people who risk
their lives as well as the families who
supported them and through your
donations you can support them too click
on the link and share your gratitude for
the people who gave so much so that we
could have so much
you